or enforcement agencies been
particularly hard-hit of this latest
news that one of their own has lost
their lives to Co vid 19 what we know
about that individual is that there were
a gendarme 51 years old and that as soon
as they felt ill they were placed into
self confinement but unfortunately the
condition worsened on Wednesday and
before the John Dom who's only been
named as Patrick G in the French media
could reach the hospital he had passed
away now that latest development has
ratcheted up the threats from police
unions that unless they are given that
protective gear that they need that they
will stop enforcing the lockdown
this is what the unions had to say in a
joint statement to the Ministry of
Interior the inter union is issuing a
solemn warning to the minister if the
means of protection are lacking police
officers will only carry out urgent
missions and will no longer enforce the
lockdown
well the lockdown in France has been
going on since March 17th and since that
around a hundred thousand fines have
been given that by the police officers
and John Dom's across the country there
are around a hundred thousand who've
been deployed to do just that but they
have been angry now since the beginning
of that lockdown over fears of the lack
of protective masks that they've had
many police unions have talked about the
fact not just that they fear because
they're coming into contact with so many
people to issue these fines to check the
permission slips that we need to be out
on the streets in France that they could
be liable to catch the virus but also
then it could be a vector of
transmission so this is something that's
really been concerning the union's since
the start
now the Ministry of interiors infuriated
their police officers and the union's
even further in the last few days after
it requisitioned the FFP - masks these
the highly protective masks took them
away and said the police officers had to
give them to the health workers now
we've been talking to one police union
in the last week about some of the fears
that they have for their members
security officers police and other
people who are polled law and order in
the country you need to be protected
this forest is not distinguished between
police
and other citizens we are not even sure
that we police officers not potentially
infecting people when we do our checks
so we need masks and other protective
equipment to keep us safe and others
well Lauren Nunez who is the junior
interior minister says that the
government is policy is to pass those
highly protective masks on to the health
workers and that they are working to
provide the police with other masks and
are working on alternatives for the
situation but this lack of masks isn't
just a problem for the police it's been
described by one nursing union here in
France as akin to a state scandal and
that's because France doesn't have
enough masks for its emergency workers
and this is just the latest headache for
the French government in the last few
days we also know that a group of medics
filed a complaint of negligence against
top officials here in France that
includes the Prime Minister Edward
Philippe saying that they didn't do
enough to avert the pandemic the corona
virus pandemic here in France and this
comes of course as France is trying to
battle against Kovach 19 as the numbers
of infected and the numbers of those who
have apparently died from Kovach 19
continue to rise
you